the Joe Rogan experience there's a few
things I don't know if this would be
interesting to go into but there's a few
things that I've found have been
somewhat successful in conversations
with people who really disagree with me
in at least like lowering the
temperature a little bit and getting
people to maybe engage in a good-faith
way one of them is how do you think I
came to my position mmm so you might be
for total free-market for-profit health
care I am for a system where the
government is more involved and even if
you can't pay you get care before we
even start if I say how do you think I
arrived at my position yeah that has
been pretty useful another example is I
think this came from Peter Boghossian
who I think you've had on yes the de
feasibility question which is what
evidence if I presented it to you would
bring you over to my side I'm not saying
I have that evidence or that it exists
but give me a framework as to what is
keeping you from seeing this my way
because sometimes that exists the person
just doesn't know about mm-hmm
those are two tools that I have found
super useful in trying to make some
headway with people who are hyper
partisan and very escalated with a lot
of these issues yeah that makes sense
yeah it's it's very difficult to have
good-faith conversations with people
when you disagree with them you know and
you have to have discipline and you have
to have some sort of a sense of self
yeah and you have to know how to be calm
and kind you know the the the the
descent into insults and dunking on
people is one of the reasons why I at
the beginning of the conversation I was
saying that I've one of the things I
enjoy about your your YouTube videos is
you're a very reasonable rational person
and you don't get crazy and animated and
insulting and I think there's we need
more of that because I think even though
you're not going to convert some people
there's a certain section of the
population that disagrees with you
that's just going to write but there's a
significant number that I'm gonna go hey
this David Pakman guys he's reasonable
he's making a lot of sense he's
intelligent well my goal is and I think
that it's sort of working and that we
have a lot of Trump supporters who are
paid subscribers to
show a lot we have some are they taking
notes maybe they are to the boss but my
my goal is my goal is yeah that would I
mean that that would be an interesting
day if I wake up and Trump has responded
to one of my videos about him what would
you do I think it'd be a good day well
that's what Colbert did that was how
funny was that when Colbert was on TVs
like Donald yeah how did you not know
that you shouldn't respond to me right
yeah yeah yeah that's rule number one
it's an important one unless you want to
create a shitstorm of a very Sir Neil my
goal is I don't pretend to be neutral
I think neutrality is almost always
false because on most issues people are
not indifferent I mean neutral is
another way of saying indifferent you
could be conflicted in neutral you could
be conflicted in neutral but I try to at
least be objective and transparent and
how I arrived at what I believe so you
can disagree with my conclusion you can
even come to me and tell me the facts
I've used to reach the conclusion or
incomplete or wrong but I'm completely
genuine and how I arrived there and I
think that that is why we have some I
mean yeah there's obviously if you look
at YouTube comments there are
right-wingers that watch my show but
choosing to support it financially is a
different thing and I get emails from
conservatives who say I don't agree with
your conclusions but I do find that
you're at least reasoning through the
issues in a way that resonates with me
and I want to support the fact that
you're doing that that's outstanding
that's a huge victory there really is in
a sense in my eyes in this day and age